the uncertainty over the spread of the
coronaviruses rattling markets the Dow
has plunged more than 2,300 points in
the last five trading days President
Trump says the risk of Americans getting
infected is low and he led an effort
yesterday to show his administration is
prepared
oh we Paula Reed is at the White House
for us Paula good morning what's the
president's mission here good morning
Tony while this press conference came
following days of conflicting messages
from the administration on coronavirus
and CBS News has learned the president
was frustrated that officials were not
projecting a more positive outlook even
as the markets tumbled so last night in
only his second ever White House
briefing room appearance the president
tried to reassure nervous Americans
we're very very ready for this for
anything flanked by health officials the
president said his administration has
plans in place for a worst-case scenario
including stockpiling protective
equipment and masks every aspect of our
society should be prepared and mr. Trump
said vice president Mike Pence will head
the task force responsible for
monitoring the outbreak and coordinating
with local officials across the country
on their response to the virus
I look forward mr. president to serving
in this role
health officials agreed with the
president that the aggressive strategy
so far had been working but were
cautious about the future we can expect
to see more cases in the United States
moments later the president contradicted
that I don't think it's inevitable and
there were other discrepancies on how
soon a vaccine may be available the
vaccine is coming along well and I'm
speaking to the doctors we think this is
something that we can develop fairly
rapidly although this is the fastest we
have ever gone from a sequence of a
virus to a trial it still would not be
any applicable to the epidemic
unless we'd really wait about a year to
a year and a half
health officials say prevention is
crucial we don't have any natural
immunity we don't have a vaccine and we
don't have antivirals to treat this so
really right now prevention is out
secure but do you
ministration has been criticized for
cutting funding that had been dedicated
to coordinating government responses to
public health crises what he's doing is
late too late
anemic hopefully we can make up for the
loss of the time the president fired
back at Speaker Pelosi calling her
incompetent but also saying they have to
be on the same team
the president says those travel
restrictions that he imposed early on in
this outbreak worked and he is open to
adding additional travel restrictions
but now he said is not the right time
Gayle
all right Paula thank you very much